[Music]
thank you
they use the stem cells from an unborn
fetus that their mother's going to have
an abortion anyway as the abortion
rather than discard that fetus they
harvest the stem cell
[Music]
we look at one of the most divisive
issues in America abortion
a torch Clinic phobia the deadly
shooting rampage at a Planned Parenthood
Clinic bothers me as the anti-abortion
people
if their kid was sick
kid had a disease if they were any type
of parent they'd be knocking everybody
out in line to be the first one here and
there's no doubt about it
see when someone dies but they choose to
donate their organs to give life I think
in collecting stem cells it's a great
way of just giving life the way I feel
about it is babies
might as well make God made something
really available if you're going to have
an abortion
don't
waste what can save someone's life I
don't want you to have an abortion but
if you're going to don't waste and
people need to realize that the
availability of wherever it comes from
is God's will another
put on studies that require fetal
tissues despite the importance of This
research due to concerns about personal
safety the significance of fetal tissue
research has been reiterated by other
leading research institutions including
Harvard the Yale School of Medicine and
the University of Minnesota
[Music]
foreign
cells fatal stem cells ever become
widely used it will change the entire
profit picture of the pharmaceutical
industry is they don't make their money
on well people they make their money on
sick people the country of Ukraine is
literally the only place on Earth where
this is legal and regulated right yeah
[Music]
and I have not had one pain episode
first time in 18 years
I am totally pain-free and medication
free
the people who have an illness who are
going to be dead 12 to 15 years should
have an alternative to sitting on the
sidelines and wait for a triple blind
Placebo flop and flops you know
experiment there should be something
else that's it's sick that we know how
to help people and cure illness and we
can't do it so we realized there was
nothing that made stream medicine had
we'd been to absolutely every doctor we
possibly could it's it's so exciting for
the first time I see the light in the
end of the tunnel I see a light
we can ease your dying
with medicine
that's not something I wanted to hear
so
going to a different country for
treatment sounds a lot better than that
I was very skeptical very skeptical it's
helped me tremendously with just one
treatment I've gone from middle school
I've had and then high school as well
almost flunking staying up until two in
the morning with my parents just so they
could help me because I couldn't even do
it myself until now I'm making Straight
A's and B's which is phenomenal so
you're saying in the four month time
that you're making better grades than
you've ever had yeah I actually
beneficial yeah actually without taking
medication now five ants ADHD Adderall
[Music]
she was diagnosed with a rare form of
muscular dystrophy after the very first
treatment within that next week she went
from falling 15 to 20 times a day down
to no times she doesn't fall anymore her
gait was really wobbly all over the
place and now she's walked super
straight to be able to walk in a
straight line something is working well
for you something is working well for me
and I'm not doing anything else so
what's important is that it is chronic
lymphocytic leukemia and that it hasn't
progressed and that you're not sick
which is why once a year like an
insurance policy I go back and get the
stem cells
I've never seen anything quite like this
I got to be honest
if I had the best I I would never think
anything like this would work I haven't
seen anybody get this well
what can I tell you except that we're
looking at
20th century miracle
and he wouldn't let him walk without
assistance
so look where we are today
I'm still an American associate
professor in chemical engineering and
Adjunct professor in mechanical
engineering at Georgia Tech I also have
Parkinson's disease tell me tell me how
you feel about today I can tell the
difference from the time the first
started doing the treatment
how do you feel about the fact that you
have to that this isn't available like
readily in the states like the opinion
in my opinion based on what I know about
it now I think it's Criminal you look at
it you're looking really good
how do you feel
I'm feeling much better yeah yeah really
is your natural setting up earlier right
yeah how do you feel that it's a lot
better it's not perfect but it's a lot
better
it's amazing I'm not traveling so much
in terms of the evolution of medicine if
you think about the 20th century we
turned chemistry to the service of
medicine that is we learned how to
deliver small molecules as drugs but if
we can learn how to deliver cells
as medicines and actually repair and
regenerate these degenerating tissues
will have a major impact on medicine I
think it's inevitable
there are many different types of stem
cells the ones we hear most about Are
embryonic stem cells
umbilical cord stem cells and adult stem
cells
these different stem cell types should
not be confused with one another as they
are not all created equal nor are they
the focus of this stem cell story
instead for this journey we focused on
fetal stem cells arguably the most
contested and controversial form of stem
cell therapy to date
I'm just trying to think I don't know
how to start talking
um
it's
a lot to tell you over
one sitting you know it's
it's hard
I see kids in wheelchairs and my
doctor's appointments and I think
wow I'm lucky
and then I see
kids in high school and I think wow I
got the short end of the stick
[Music]
I don't do the things that I used to
anymore
I don't really leave the house at all
because it's hard I mean
I live on my couch and in my kitchen and
in my room
and I don't choose to I don't
I don't mean to ignore my friends
because I don't want to hang out with
them because it's hard to
I don't
go to music shows like I used to because
that's something I'm really passionate
about
and that's the only thing that I cared
and I can't even get up the stairs
without
having to sit in
catch hold of myself
because my heart beats extremely fast
and I feel like I'm about to pass out
so now what they're offering us as far
as his cystic fibrosis team is a double
lung transplant
which you know the horrors of that I can
only imagine I know my son does not want
that
and there's no guarantee with that
either no they even said that you know
there's some people who go through it
and wish that they didn't
lung transplant is where you need to go
if you think about it we can ease your
dying with medicine
that's not something I wanted to hear
so
going to a different country for
treatment sounds a lot better than that
I've started visualizing going over the
Border
and I've started
fantasizing about the results he's 21
years old and he should be out living
his life and dating and having a job and
going to school or whatever he wants to
do he pretty much just exists in this
house it's really hard for me
and then when we found out that there is
another option once that was totally
realized then I remember being pissed
yeah man yeah why this is not available
readily available to
it's not talked about
hey we're Alton that's it
people living with cystic fibrosis most
always experience a steady worsening of
their disease with time
yet Brandon has just gained seven pounds
and at the time he received his first
round of fetal stem cells in December of
2014. his lung capacity was only 16
percent
awesome and now his lung capacity is at
24 percent
while fetal stem cells can't repair the
genetic mutation that causes Cystic
Fibrosis it is Brandon's hope that fetal
stem cells will prolong his need for a
double lung transplant or perhaps avoid
the transplants altogether
[Music]
simply put stem cells are unspecified
cells that transform into specified
cells these Blank Slate cells can become
everything from a heart cell to a brain
cell we all have stem cells in our
bodies however when it comes to options
within stem cell therapy most of the
public doesn't understand the
differences between their types so here
is a brief overview
umbilical cord stem cells are cord or
placental blood cells that are saved at
Birth however umbilical cord blood
transplants have limitations as
treatment of adults with cord blood has
so far proved to be very challenging up
until recently they are only really
known to treat blood diseases while
there are a handful of clinical trials
recently opened for non-blood-related
diseases in children using Cord Blood
requires a genetic match and there is no
guarantee that your cord blood will
spontaneously transform into the
required specialized cells to help with
your ailment and be forewarned if you
are currently expecting a child and plan
on banking your child's cord blood it's
important to realize that gaining access
to your own child's cord blood cells is
no easy task we spent approximately four
thousand dollars for his cells and when
it came down to my disease per se
happened to be autism I could not get
them they would not release them to me
even though I mean I went all the way to
the top they advertise that they will be
able to do this this and this that did
not happen I could not get them when I
finally got to the head of ViaCord when
I asked finally how many Have You
released the answer I received from The
Clinical Director was one I I bought
them I paid for them and I could not get
them
adult stem cells are the most popular
and the least controversial where
scientists Harvest your own stem cells
process them and give them back to you
in hopes of repairing damaged tissues
however there are currently several
limitations to using adult stem cells
adult stem cells are often present in
only minute quantities and therefore can
be difficult to isolate and purify adult
stem cells may also contain more DNA
abnormalities caused by sunlight toxins
and errors in making more DNA copies
during the course of a lifetime
there has been recent Buzz about how
scientists can now reprogram adult stem
cells to behave like embryonic stem
cells but they are still adulterated
cells and may also suffer DNA
abnormalities the use of embryonic stem
cells has been a hot topic of public
debate so much so that President George
W bush banned all federal funding for
embryonic stem cell research in 2007
only to be overturned by President
Barack Obama two years later embryonic
stem cells are unadulterated stem cells
that can be easily grown in a Petri dish
and harvested within the first five days
of development but they also come with
limitations the ability of embryonic
stem cells to form non-cancerous tumors
called teratomas is one of their
defining traits it's a frightening one
particularly for those who hope to
develop therapies from these cells
what makes fetal stem cells uniquely
different is because the fetus provides
stem cells harvested from nearly all
relevant organs the fetus contains pure
unadulterated stem cells right out of
the gate after all these stem cells have
only nine months to create an entire
human being and harvesting them is quite
easy a woman decides that she wants an
abortion and then is given the option to
have her fetus discarded or donated to
science
when fetal stem cells are injected the
idea is that they go into our body's
nervous and immune system and hone in on
areas that need repair this basic
biological phenomenon is also observed
between a mother and child during
pregnancy
fetal cells migrate into the mother
during pregnancy and can persist for
decades fetal cells also appear to
Target sites of injury Crossing both the
placental and blood-brain barriers
fetal cells appear to change into
whatever specific type of cell is needed
so fetal cells in a mother with liver
damage could transform into liver cells
so to summarize in order for umbilical
embryonic or adult stem cells to be
effective they must spontaneously
transform into the different cell types
of our body while fetal stem cells also
work the same way they already contain
the unadulterated building blocks of our
nervous and immune systems
while The Logical superiority of fetal
stem cells makes sense when observed
objectively their research and use has
sparked a political Firestorm Iran and
Planned Parenthood killing babies in
America the 30 to 100 Chrysler events
per specimen that we're talking about
right yeah this makes deciphering facts
from fiction in the media near
impossible as special interest groups
will only defend stem cell types that
fit within their agenda look at whenever
there's a new story of a great success
with stem cells it's always adult stem
cells
and leaving current fetal stem cell
researchers to work in the shadows out
of fear for their lives
[Music]
what the doctors told us in the United
States is that Joey his lifespan that
might not meet out of his teens because
of his heart and lungs and you know he'd
be in a wheelchair before he's even 10.
this is my son Joey he has muscular
dystrophy limb girdle
and uh that's that's wasting of the
muscles um
throughout the whole body eventually
mainly it starts in the shoulders and
the hips
the disease was being pretty aggressive
so I probably couldn't get him in here
fast enough really once I did my
research
since then you know he has maintained
his heart his lungs are full strength
how do the doctors feel about his
Improvement I told him what we were
doing and uh you know at first they told
me not to uh not to do it you know that
you know if there's not enough research
on it there's not enough documentation
on it but after we got back from the
first or even the second time
basically they said keep doing what
you're doing because they don't see it
anywhere they see thousands of patients
a month a year you know I'm not sure
exact number and there's never they
never get better they always get worse
and it's aggressive most of the kids
that were his age with the same disease
are not mobile right now and uh as you
can see he stands straight so this is
something that should be should be
readily available to everybody there
should be scientists working
around the clock on this instead of uh
trying to make pills you know
people I have to tell people that I have
Parkinson's nobody would ever believe it
so it's it's it's it's big since the
treatment I've always been active and
play golf my lowest golf score was a 77
and since then I have shot even par I
don't have the shakes and trimmers so
that makes a big difference in in being
able to walk 18 holes the physical
liabilities that incur on most people
with Parkinson's you just can't do that
oh it's remarkable before we had trouble
walking ever since he's come back the
last time he's like
this whole sale I've known Steve for
about I'd say I'd say about 10 years now
but I've been playing golf with him for
a number of years too and that's where
I've noticed most of his Affliction you
know you could see the similarities to
uh who's the actor that had Parkinson's
Michael Phelps I think and so he had a
lot of those same things a shakiness and
and whatnot and then
I guess it was probably two to three
weeks ago I saw Steve out here playing
he wasn't playing with our group but I
saw him I I saw somebody that I thought
might be Steve everyone in the group
commented uh that looks like Steve now
because he wasn't you know having
trouble getting started walking and I
and I thought no that that that's not
Steve because he was he was walking
normally and so uh sure enough it was
him and
check
good shot
and uh
it was obvious that something had
happened
and now he's really walking just just
like the rest of us it really appears to
be miraculous
now he's shooting he's playing better
than the rest of us and so he's had a
dramatic Improvement I have a wonderful
physical therapist most patients are
progressive with with the Parkinson's
but um his spirits are high I think and
I'm very encouraged I think by the
treatment so he's working hard to to
continue to improve
I actually bowed last week goes to 278
which is the highest game I've ever
bowled in my life
before
you could ask me if my doctor knew and I
told you I never told him because he had
mentioned to me that if he could take me
to a convention that he would win doctor
of the year because I was doing so good
Steve's story is somewhat unique during
this investigation I found that not
everyone with Parkinson's got better
fetal stem cells only appeared to help
those with Parkinson's who were recently
diagnosed usually within one to two
years like Steve and the case of Carolyn
Porter so my husband and I sat down at
the table and I remember that night that
I took my fork and I started to take a
bite and my hand started trimming
trembling so bad that I couldn't stop I
took the left hand and I finally was
able to take a bite well for a year and
a half I had been going to my computer
every single night and I would type in
Parkinson disease
and stem cell popped up on my computer
and I thought
I didn't type in stem cell what is stem
cell I had gotten to the point that I
couldn't walk and I certainly couldn't
talk
I went in May of
2013. when I came through the airport
everything was in a wheelchair they told
me there were no guarantees so we we
were wide open we knew there were no
guarantees and they said it would be up
to six months probably if the stem cell
helped me well we finished the treatment
on a Saturday and we came back to the
hotel and we left on a Sunday going home
I said to my husband I think I can walk
they said oh no no you can't walk she
informed me on the way home that I
didn't need the help of that she could
get up and walk on room and she did
which was very surprising
we got to the to the airplane and I just
could tell that I was getting better
three days after I had the stem cell
treatment I just started speaking
correctly all of a sudden it was like
everything stopped
it was like there were no more Tremors
there were no more head shaking it was
maybe 10 days after she got back
she got out of her car and I literally I
mean it just I had cold chills because
she could walk
we sat down her hands did not move she
did not jerk she could carry on a
conversation without stuttering and we
both just sat and cried and I promise
you everything stopped
I was well
and
I was the most happiest person in the
world I played the piano all the time
well for two years I couldn't play the
piano I'm just I'm not a really good
pianist my thing when I get home from
work the first thing I do is turn the
news on and watch it and while I'm
sitting in my easy chair but I always
get interrupted by Carolyn playing the
piano which interferes with my
television
considering the fact that she is being
able to play the piano is a good reason
that I don't have to have to watch the
news every night my doctor was he just
couldn't believe it he calls me his
Miracle patient so I don't need any
medication anymore
foreign at the moment the largest stem
cell research agency in the world is
serm or the California Institute for
regenerative medicine a multi-billion
dollar agency that was voted into
existence in 2004 by the citizens of
California we are an agency that was
created to help patients and our mission
is to accelerate stem cell treatments to
those patients with unmet medical needs
since their Inception more than a decade
ago they've faced some criticism from
the media for what they perceive as a
lack of progress with the LA Times
calling them a six billion dollar public
investment that was born in height but
it appears the mainstream media hasn't
truly investigated why cerm's efforts
are moving so slow welcome to the
December board meeting for cerm this
observation was further confirmed when
we found ourselves to essentially be one
of the only members of the media
attending serm's 2015 science
subcommittee board meeting in Los
Angeles cerms board consists of a
colorful assortment of members from
doctors and scientists retired Senator
art Torres former CEO of Paramount
Pictures Sherry Lansing to actress
writer director Lauren Miller Seth
Rogen's wife
at the time of this meeting cerm
announced the commencement of 15
clinical trials three of which involve
fetal stem cells while cerm has plenty
of money and influential people at the
helm they repeatedly expressed that
their biggest impediment isn't science
or money but the FDA a regulatory agency
that continues to insist on applying the
drug development model for a
conventional drug to Stem Cell
treatments which is like forcing a round
peg into a square hole seventy percent
of respondents to our surveys listed
fda's single biggest impediment to
developing stem cell therapies from the
time we discover a stem cell product
that looks promising to the time we can
actually get an IND approved by the FDA
to where we can start we can start doing
clinical trials that right now for stem
cell therapies is too long it's
somewhere between six to eight years the
industry average for anything that's not
a stem cell is 3.2 years and so we look
at that and we say okay that's a problem
cell therapies are either either
essentially unregulated by FDA and very
little regular should take you less than
a hundred thousand dollars and take you
less than three months uh to comply or
they are excessively regulated by FDA
where it costs greater than a billion
dollars and it takes longer than than 12
years and there's nothing in between and
all the other disciplines of medicine
have something in between in other words
to address this growing field in 2001
the FDA created a new tiered approach
Paradigm to deal with the approval of
stem cell therapies by allowing certain
stem cell therapies they deem safe like
adult stem cells to Simply exist without
regulation While most all other stem
cell Technologies including fetal stem
cells are forced to go through at least
a 12-year one billion dollar regulatory
process just to reach the market we also
know that stem cell therapies from a
commercial standpoint uh clear clearly
uh our our disadvantage so big Pharma uh
companies will disproportionately in
license non-cell Technologies at a much
greater rate than than cell Technologies
only eight percent of serums programs
actually have Partners the reason there
is no commercial interest is because
stem cells are just biology that anyone
with the proper resources can harness
they simply can't be patented or placed
into the current Monopoly driven
pharmaceutical Paradigm the very idea
that an increasing number of people are
discovering this technology many of whom
no longer require the pharmaceutical
medications they were expected to be
prescribed for the rest of their lives
is an extremely frightening reality to
the current business Paradigm the
pharmaceutical industry has relied on
for decades and since the fda's drug
evaluation department has literally been
purchased by the pharmaceutical industry
due to Congress passing the drug user
fee act with nearly one billion dollars
of the fda's annual 1.3 billion dollar
drug evaluation budget coming directly
from the pharmaceutical industry it is
supposed to be regulating there is no
logical reason the medical industry is
going to loosen its reins on this
groundbreaking technology anytime soon
in fact the FDA recently began providing
members of the U.S Congress with
one-sided information reporting only the
dangers of stem cell treatments much of
which was outdated and does not reflect
what is documented in the clinical
literature these actions cast the FDA in
a very unfavorable life and seem to make
it appear that they are actively
lobbying against a therapeutic modality
for which they are responsible for
fostering we're not anti-regulation
we're not anti-fdi a
um but we we also will not ignore that
there's a problem we reject outright the
notion that a regulatory pathway that
takes over 15 years and costs over 2
billion dollars is the only way to go
that's not that's not an acceptable
approach the demand the need is very
real patients really are suffering they
really are desperate they really do need
help
the entities the researchers and the
companies that have the solutions view
in in some respects the barriers between
their their current therapies and those
patients as insurmountable then lastly
with respect to centers that operate
either overseas or underneath the
jurisdiction of of FDA that is a symptom
of the problem they take their products
and their Technologies overseas where
they're not they're not subject to the
same regulatory constraints the common
denominator is we're not doing anything
that's meaningfully advancing the field
and helping the patients due to this
reality people like Lawrence Simon who
was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis a
few years ago aren't going to just sit
around waiting for any well-meaning
agency to catch up and alter a
regulatory system that doesn't want to
change have you ever spoken to your
doctor about what you're doing I have
there's no dreamer which there was
initially how about your grasp squeeze
good
very good it's right there very good
ordinarily in your experience if you
don't mind me asking correct um
considering how many years ago he's been
diagnosed 2011 like what do you usually
see some people will just go on down the
trail and become worse and worse and
worse and become better
which I have seen and they'll fail every
therapy
he's basically reached I would say a
plateau and stabilized where
he's no longer declining
I'm very impressed with what I'm looking
at I gotta tell
and I've been at it 50 years almost that
ought to takes him and he's been my
patient for about 30.
so what do we say about all this I don't
know except to say that
there's something that works there I
don't think it's anything we're giving
them I really don't
from what I've seen in the failures I've
seen
I'm pleased what else can I tell you
yeah that's all I wanted to hear is just
to be honest tell you the truth I
thought it was crap I'd tell you that
too
I'm the first one ask him
I see a lot of stuff that's bogus I was
not in the beginning enthusiastic about
all this I said well
if you got the money to waste go ahead
but then again you're talking about a
disease you can't cure so with what we
have so why not
and I'm you know proof of the pudding I
haven't seen anybody get this well
now you think I was a Salesman for the
thing
but you know what salesman no salesman
I'm glad to see them better
whatever it takes
and he wouldn't let him walk without
assistance
so look where we are today
the MRI with diagnostic he had lesions
all over the place in January 2011 After
experiencing weakness and vertigo
Lawrence's neurologist ordered an MRI
which would find many areas of
abnormality favoring active disease
numerous lesions and plaques were found
representing active multiple sclerosis
a few weeks after this appointment on
March 25th Lawrence had another MRI
which found no new areas of abnormality
and no abnormal lesions
[Music]
Susie became a patient 31 years ago she
was frequently ill with recurring
respiratory illnesses intermittent
swelling of lymph glands frequently
treated with antibiotics in 2004 she
became more severely ill and more
persistently presented with lymph glands
that were swollen all over her body in
consideration of the fact that she has a
family history of a lymphocytic
malignancy it was appropriate to further
investigate why her lymph glands were
remaining swollen and weren't getting
better after treatment for infectious
causes this was the bone marrow biopsy
it confirmed she had a condition called
chronic lymphocytic leukemia
most people with the condition do have
Progressive illness and that it can
convert to a serious life-threatening
malignancy it was interesting as we have
followed her in the past 10 years that
there has been no progression of her
lymphocytic leukemia and in fact there's
been Improvement in the number of
abnormal cells relative to normal cells
in her blood her lymph glands have
remained normal they responded very
quickly to treatments that she received
at the time you've got probably the most
carefully documented body in my practice
in terms of you know six to eight inches
of paper charts before the new
computerized records started in 2006
which if we were to print them out would
likely occupy several boxes of computer
paper
and we've been testing your Laboratories
frequently
and I do have to acknowledge that we're
not finding anything wrong with you or
evidence of any side effects from the
treatments that you've received what's
important is that it is chronic
lymphocytic leukemia and that it hasn't
progressed and that you're not sick the
majority of people don't have that
experience
so the doctor seeing somebody with clo
initially figures will be okay for a few
years and then we're going to have
trouble are you talking about 2004 so
you're talking about 11 years ago that
you've had this diagnosis right correct
and based on the fact that my father
started out okay with chronic and ended
up with a cute
I wasn't going to do that understandably
Susie's doctor was quite nervous to talk
to us on camera hence his modesty not
only did Susie's chronic lymphocytic
leukemia not progress to acute
Pathologists were baffled at the unusual
finding that her cells normalized which
means Her diagnosis was reversed or
cured in order to have a diagnosis of
chronic lymphocytic leukemia it requires
an absolute b-cell count of over five
thousand Susie's absolute b-cell count
reduced to 304 Susie underwent no other
medical intervention For Her diagnosis
other than receiving a series of fetal
stem cell injections part of my
discomfort being part of this project
I'm making myself the target
but realistically stem cell therapy is
becoming more mainstream
it is important that people know about
it and that we learn more about it my
preference would be that it was done in
a scientific way
that we can all learn from our
experiences and if we don't have
explorers we never learn anything
chance right I mean it's a shot it's
working well well something is working
well for you something is working well
for me and I'm not doing anything else
so
we're good yes we are we are good
you're welcome
when she decided to have the stem cells
initially as a and the somewhat
skeptical I became more and more
convinced of the benefit as the years
went on that she just got better and
better
uh and very honestly
when you go to medical school I think
they put a pair of horse blinders on you
and that unless it's taught in medical
school or you read it in the medical
literature it can't be can't be valid
can't happen Susie is a living proof
she's healthier than I am considering I
have some conditions my own that I think
could possibly be benefit I actually
considering having uh the stem cells
myself
I've been through
about 14
doctors
I mean she was going to extremes to try
and just lift the pain off just a little
bit she even cut her hair off because
she figured that that would help her
neck when I look back and I think about
all the doctor visits I remember being
in the office with Danny and whatever
physician we were with at that time
and then say well it's in her head or
something to that nature I could see her
eyes fill up with tears and I would just
put my hands on her face and I would say
to her I am not going to stop you will
not suffer one
more day
if I have anything to do about it I got
my wisdom teeth taken out and I got
prescribed the medication that she got
prescribed for
just if she had a really bad day you
know here take some narcotics you know
in late 2013 a genetic test finally
helped doctors diagnose Danny with
ankylosing spondylitis
this is a type of inflammatory arthritis
that primarily affects the spine causing
the ligaments to become inflamed the
cartilage then fuses to the vertebrae
causing the spine to fuse
causing immobility
after all Medical Treatments failed to
help Danny from a host of
anti-inflammatories to Methotrexate
which is a chemotherapy drug usually
given to cancer patients as well as
tumor necrosis Factor Inhibitors and
some of the most powerful narcotics
available she then underwent fetal stem
cell therapy in Mexico on July 25th
2014.
she had this smile from ear to ear
I hadn't seen that smile in so long
the minivan brought her back to our
hotel she says mom let's go for a walk
let's go shopping and go out to eat and
I was like what who are you
within a week of getting the stem cells
I stopped taking all of my medicines
they weren't allowing me to be me
they changed my personality so much
and that's something that stem cells has
given me it's given me
the ability to be me because I don't
have to
poison my body
with
all the other medicines that change who
I am
[Music]
Danny is now a division one athlete
whose rowing team reached the NCAA
championships
rowing is probably one of the most
physically demanding Sports you can do
it works every single muscle in your
body
I had no clue with even all of my hours
of research that this type of therapy
was even available
most people find out about fetal stem
cell therapy By Word of Mouth Danny's
mother discovered it by looking for a
used truck for her son if it wasn't for
me meeting Jan good
over finding that perfect truck for my
son
I don't know what we would have done
said wow I can't believe that you're
here I can't believe God sent you here
he didn't send you here for this truck
he sent you here to hear this
meet Jan good and her 16 year old
adopted daughter Mariah
two years ago when Mariah was 14 years
old she was diagnosed with fibromyalgia
as well as juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
as well as systemic lupus erythematosus
I first met Mariah about three years ago
in April 2012. she and her mom had just
moved down from Tennessee and she came
in for an office visit she had been
diagnosed with lupus in Tennessee
however shortly after moving to Florida
she started having problems with joint
pain knee pain back pain and it really
limited her ability to do the things
that she enjoyed doing like playing
basketball and so at that point we
considered having her see a
rheumatologist and the rheumatologist's
concern was again lupus along with her
having juvenile arthritis and so as part
of the treatment regimen at that point
she was placed on
a couple chemotherapy agents so the
rheumatologist put Mariah on
Methotrexate which is a chemo drug and
prednisone and he kept increasing the
dosage she could not get out of bed she
could barely make it to the bathroom
barely make it to eat by April of 2013
lab reports found blood in Mariah's
urine signaling the beginning of kidney
failure so that's when Audrey the London
just said no more no more chemo no more
of the steroids I was desperate I took a
white sheet and wrote on there hope for
Mariah give Mariah alive something about
stem cell treatment and literally hung
it in her front yard
and people started donating furniture
and different things and we had garage
sales and people would just randomly
knock on our door and hand us twenty
dollars or a hundred dollars for her
stem cell treatment and then I ended up
putting a sheet in the back on the on
the um fence the city had a fit they
made me take both of them down it was
they didn't like it and I guess it was
because it was more old-fashioned
country redneck way of dealing with the
problems but it worked you know it got
us who we need to be I'm gonna put her
in a wheelchair and got her on the plane
and we were all nervous because we'd
never been to Mexico what's this going
to be like and your mind's like well is
this really real and is this going to
work and you're all emotional and and
they gave my baby alive
on the ride back to San Diego I remember
her saying I feel happy I feel hyper and
she got you really giggly and so we went
back to the motel that we were staying
at and she ate and I went to do laundry
besides the laundry room was a exercise
room and she said Mom can I go up here
and get on this and see how what happens
I go yes but take it very very slow
because your muscles you know I haven't
been working in a year and a half and
did you come out and she goes come here
I want to show you something and I mean
I'll sit there and I'm watching people
playing 20 years
I'm fine Mom I'm having fun
three hours after the stem cell
treatment
she done two miles on the elliptical and
then jumped on the treadmill and done
two more miles she said
she see Mom don't have a whole lot of
background in terms of the
uses of the therapy however if it seems
to be it seems to have made a difference
in her life I guess it's something that
can situated something that was a
benefit to her just when we thought this
story couldn't possibly get more
interesting
Janet good had also been dealing with
her own health issues incredibly one
year after Mariah's recovery her adopted
mother Janet was diagnosed with systemic
lupus erythematosis as well as
dermatomyositis
I never dreamed then a year later that I
would be given a death sentence of three
months to two years
and I would need stem cells so finding
the stem cells for Mariah and it's
saving her life in turn
I needed them and it saved my life you
got to pass it on you got to tell
everybody what you've been through and
how it's helped you because it can save
their life too or maybe one of their
family members why in a tragic turn of
events on November 6 2016 Mariah was
shot and killed
it was still
now that light's been snuffed out
and taken away by somebody with anger
issues
not only do people seek fetal stem cells
for various immunological and
neurological ailments some of the
world's busiest professionals are
seeking fetal stem cells for anti-aging
better performance and overall longevity
this is George schlotter a multi Emmy
award-winning American Comedy television
icon he's best known for his work as a
founding producer and writer for the
groundbreaking television comedy classic
Rowan and Martin's laughing
is a powerful powerful tool for good for
good health I took the injection myself
and when I came home my wife looked at
me she said well what what happened to
you where have you been right it wasn't
a high it wasn't like any kind of drug
or anything it was just a sense of
well-being it wasn't even Euphoria it
was just sense of being coupled so I
took the injection and I then took some
people down there including my wife and
including my daughter and I cannot
understand the resistance to it except
for the fact that if stem cells fetal
stem cells ever become widely used it
will change the entire profit picture of
the pharmaceutical industry because they
don't make their money on well people
they make their money on sick people and
continually pumping drugs of all kinds
into them that is how the medical
profession survives on drugs medical
profession is great they do great things
I wouldn't want to have a plumber
deliver a baby but
they resist this out of the opinion that
this will change the whole profit
structure of the medical profession and
it will it's coming it's just a question
of when they resisted Jonah Salk and
having had Polio I wish they'd stopped
resisting before I got it my favorite is
they said there hasn't been a
double-blind study
there's been double-blind studies on a
lot of the drugs that killed people
there's been double-blind studies on
chemotherapy which we know a lot of
people have not survived it's just that
it kind of makes me very very
uncomfortable to think
that
waiting for some kind of a double-blind
study that would result in the death of
one child and the Cure of another my
question always is how do you select
which child to treat with a placebo or
which child to treat with these stem
cells you should feel stem cells is
anywhere near as dangerous as cough
medicine it can kill you
this is the late William Raider the once
owner of stem cell of America a company
that today is barely operating most of
the patients you've seen so far were
treated by Raider in Tijuana Mexico
before his company ran out of the fetal
stem cells that Raider stole from M cell
in Kiev Ukraine
earlier in my career I was one of the
first medical experts on television
starting out first in radio then
eventually appearing multiple times on
the Merv Griffin Show Dr William Raider
not good
his successful television career
continued well into the 1990s I received
a phone call from Eastern Europe and
they called me and told me about fetal
stem cells so I said to him I'll tell
you what I want to see this I want to
interview you I want to interview
patients I want to just do whatever I
want to do when I'm there would you
agree to that they said yes 10 days
later I'm an air Ukraine plane
it totally blew my mind what I saw in
1995 William Raider traveled to Kiev
Ukraine and spent some time with the
founders of a Medical University Clinic
called emsel this is the late Alexander
smigadu who in 1991 is the man
originally responsible for inventing and
developing the technological innovation
of fetal stem cell therapy along with
emsel's co-founder and partner Alexi
carpenko who you will meet later
professor smigadu and Professor carpenko
taught William Raider the basic
techniques of fetal stem cell
transplantation according to Professor
Alexi carpenko emsel was looking to
partner with William Raider on a new
clinic but William instead stole a batch
of fetal neuronal and liver cells and
started charging people money for the
stolen cells using his own company
instead I dropped everything else and I
dedicated myself to fetal stem cell
research but his research consisted of
nothing more than selling stolen cells
to his patients and while in production
on this documentary the California
medical board revoked his medical
license in their failed attempt to stop
him nonetheless us I decided to get the
injections from stem cell of America and
felt absolutely nothing my therapy
consisted of two injections they
performed no preliminary testing and the
entire process took about 30 minutes as
with anything being done while avoiding
Federal Regulations telling this part of
the story was difficult Raider had no
research lab and the only reason the
patients you met in this story so far
had such great Improvement was because
they were treated before Raider ran out
of cells
so to truly get to the bottom of this
convoluted story I traveled to msel in
Kiev Ukraine where this technology got
its start more than 20 years ago and
what better way to fully understand
fetal stem cell therapy than to
experience it by the world's original
pioneers
while undergoing M cell's three-day
longevity anti-aging program M cell
allowed me to document my entire
treatment program and film their
Laboratories and Facilities unlike most
medical clinics in the United States
msel tested my blood and urine in their
lab on site
it is from these lab results in addition
to a full ultrasound and
electrocardiogram that M cells doctors
designed a special protocol just for me
which consisted of a variety of fetal
stem cell types
a three-day facial using fetal stem
cells
hyperbaric oxygen sessions and even
massage to help keep my circulatory
system flowing nicely to allow the stem
cell transplants to properly take hold
so on day one after all my preliminary
testing was complete I was moved to a
private room where I enjoyed some coffee
and an all-organic breakfast I ordered
from the menu while I waited for my
primary physician to arrive this is Dr
Irina who is both a medical doctor and a
PhD working regularly behind the scenes
in expanding M cells research and
development of fetal stem cell
technology this is Lena one of msel's
managers and the translator assigned to
me at the start of each day Dr Irina
checked all my Vital Signs and asked me
various questions related to My overall
health after my physical exam Dr Irina
carefully explained my entire fetal stem
cell treatment program which was an
incredibly complex array of a variety of
fetal stem cell types that were
harvested between 7 to 12 weeks of
gestation and scheduled across a
three-day period to seek a variety of
goals to improve my overall health
the combination of fetal stem cells
given to me on day one helps to create
new capillaries and other small vessels
across all of my organs which help to
deliver more oxygen and nutrition
throughout my body thus improving
overall functions in my organ tissues
these cells also have very positive
effects on the inner wall of big blood
vessels therefore protecting my vessels
from
atherosclerosis and if there is any
current atherosclerosis it prevents it
from progressing they have a very
positive effect on the liver blood
formation bone marrow immune and
hormonal systems essentially giving my
entire immune system a full reboot they
started first with a standard sodium
chloride saline drip to open up my veins
followed by some anti-allergy meds just
to be on the safe side and after all of
this settled in they brought in my first
round of fetal stem cells
then it was off to see their masseuse
Yuri the massage was about an hour
back to my room for a little lunch and
relaxation
followed by hyperbaric oxygen I had
never been in a hyperbaric oxygen
chamber before it feels sort of like
flying in an airplane only with perfect
high density oxygenated air quality
I'm doing fantastic thank you
oxygen sessions are healthy anyway but
in this case it serves as further
nutrition for the fetal stem cells and
then I was off to the cosmetologist for
the first day of my facial my
cosmetologist was Helena who first gave
my face a thorough cleaning before
applying the key ingredients of this
cosmetic therapy corion cells which
Helena had already prepared shortly
before my facial began corion cells are
early fetal membrane cells that are rich
in high density nutrition vitamins and
minerals these cells are highly
anti-inflammatory and regenerative when
applied to the skin and M cell is the
only place in the world offering chorion
cells as part of a cosmetic facial
the chorion cells were then carefully
brushed onto my face
Helena then applied a Rejuvenation mask
containing aloe vera and other
ingredients to end the session
and this was the end of my first day of
treatment and they also provided
transportation to and from the clinic
each day at the end of day one I really
wanted to do some sightseeing in the
beautiful city of Kiev but msl's doctors
requested that I take it easy and not
exert myself too much I stayed downtown
near the Central Square of Kiev which
provided a plethora of hotels shopping
and food
day two
Dr Irina checked my vitals and I was
given a second round of the same fetal
stem cells I received on day one off to
massage
and then round two of hyperbaric oxygen
this is Dr Maria who was supervising my
sessions not only is Dr Maria a medical
doctor she received her PhD in fetal
stem cell therapy back to my room where
Dr Irina inspected my abdomen to prepare
me for my first subcutaneous injections
of the cells that will improve my
neuronal or nervous system these cells
improve all processes regulated by my
nervous system improving all
interneuronal connections improving
motor skills as well as my autonomic
nervous system like heart rate digestion
respiratory rate and pupillary response
while also improving memory
concentration sleep and overall
cognition essentially giving my entire
nervous system a healthy reboot after a
standard saline drip was completed this
combination of cells were injected
subcutaneous nicely into the fat of my
abdomen the reason for the location of
these injections is because the fat of
our bodies hold the most stable
temperature and allow overall protection
of these cells as they adjust to my body
and begin to slowly release into my
nervous system
and finally day two of my facial Helena
started first by placing Steam on my
face to open up the pores followed by
applying more corion cells
after allowing the chorion concentration
to be absorbed by my skin Helena
prepared an alginate mask at a very cold
temperature to then close my pores
sealing the chorion cells inside and
further stimulating micro blood
circulation
that was it for day two
wow
well at least at emsel as I decided it
was time to do a little sightseeing the
city of Kiev is gorgeous and Rich with
history and culture
[Music]
during my journey I met an American from
Pennsylvania who was in love with Kiev
as much as me I've spent a total of now
12 weeks here over the last year and
this is one of the most wonderful City
I've ever been in Mr Demarco is also an
M cell patient 18 years ago I had a very
bad motorcycle accident and along with
many other injuries I suffered a broken
vertebrae spinal cord damage and my
brachial plexus nerve group was a
bolster torn out on my right side
there's nerves control my right lung my
scapula right arm after multiple
reconstructive surgeries I was left with
severe spinal cord nerve damage pain I
was prescribed morphine mexotine
Neurontin
many different narcotics unfortunately
none of them worked they would somewhat
lessen the pain for short periods of
time but nothing would stop it I became
addicted to the morphine after two years
was taking over 200 milligrams of
morphine a day let me describe the pain
the pain there was two types of pain it
was a 24 7 type of compression squeezing
pain which was more bearable than the
shooting pains that I experienced the
shooting pains I could liken to a
knitting needle that was heated over a
flame and plugged into a wall and then
stuck in your funny belt and they would
stick it in there for about 30 seconds
and pull it out then stick it in there
for 30 seconds and pull it out Jump
Ahead to a year and a half ago I was
here in Kiev on some personal business
and found out about the stem cell Clinic
M cell there were no promises given to
me just that in the past it had helped
people in my situation I was advised to
wait two or three months before I
started tapering off the medication that
I was on that was lessening the
frequency of the episodes and I have not
had one pain episode since the end of
December first time in 18 years I am
totally pain-free and medication free
foreign
Dr Irina checked my vitals as usual
and then time for my second round of
subcutaneous injections but this round
of subcutaneous injections was an array
of fetal stem cells to help me with my
entire
musculoskeletal system which helps to
improve my bones cartilage tendons
ligaments and my joints and all their
connective tissues improving overall
metabolic processes while also
increasing trophic and elasticity of my
skin also increasing energy levels
triggering regeneration Rejuvenation and
overall high efficiency which also by
the way includes a great Improvement of
sexual functions essentially giving my
entire metabolic system a nice reboot
the reasons for the location of these
injections is the same for the cells I
received on day two
[Music]
my third massage
and then back to my room where they gave
me an IV drip of amino acids to further
improve my body's environment giving the
fetal stem cells the best chance of
doing their job and finally it was back
to my room where Dr Irina spends a great
deal of time summarizing my entire
treatment program reviewing my blood
urine and other tests they performed and
explaining to me why they gave me the
types of injections and therapy they did
each patient's undergoing therapy at
msil has a completely different
personalized therapeutic schedule
depending on their current health or any
more serious ailments they may have
since I'm pretty healthy already I
underwent M cell's longevity anti-aging
program but others with specific
ailments would receive a different
protocol I met the kalahar family who
had just arrived from Houston Texas
whose youngest son Beckham underwent
msel's purse treatment protocol for
autism
this is Beckham's father Matt
and his mother Terry while there on day
three I had the privilege to meet Dr
Alexi carpenko the original co-founder
and partner at emsel
um
rather positive results but the only
thing that I should warn you this will
not be most probably complete recovery
most of his functions will benefit
but full recovery we have not observed
we understand we understand we we we're
seeking quality of life Improvement
punish your success thank you I
appreciate that thank you very much
considering that autism currently
strikes one in every 45 children in the
United States costing each family
supporting a child with autism over the
course of his or her lifetime as much as
2.4 million dollars to care for such a
diagnosis I was quite interested in
seeing how Beckham fared after fetal
stem cell treatment so four months later
I traveled to the kalahar's hometown of
Houston Texas to see if Beckham had made
any progress we had a lot of aggression
Beckham would scratch me he would bite
me so I would go to bed nightly and I
would have Bloody sheets I would have
scratch marks there would be on my face
my back wherever I'm talking full-on
biting full-on scratching full-on
bruising all gone we had no eye contact
I would try to get in his face Becca
back and back up in his world he would
just look straight past me he looked
straight past
it was really really really difficult
but the eye contact was absolutely not
there period it was even more than that
when you looked in his eyes it was
almost as if you were looking in his
eyes and you were you weren't seeing any
nobody was home he wouldn't respond to
his name he wouldn't respond to anything
and it was pretty drastic when that
happened almost immediately after he had
his stem cell transplant we saw changes
he had this terrible eczema everywhere
all over his skin within three days it
was gone I have fought that eczema for
years with prednisone you name it I've
tried dietary changes it was gone his
skin was clear his eyes turned bright
all of a sudden these Smiles I had not
seen in years
we started swimming he could not swim
before he gets his head underwater he
loves it
before his stem cell transplant he would
not walk for me I always had to carry
him he would just block my body and
refuse to walk I couldn't walk him
around the block at three I had to have
a stroller all of a sudden he's walking
he walks now holds my hand like a
neurotypical child and we walk we can
walk in the park I can walk with him to
the grocery store to the mall that might
not seem like a big deal to parents that
are used to it but for those that aren't
able to have a child to walk it's a huge
deal so the fact that I could do that
made my life so much easier so I'm not
holding a 45 pound kid 18 bags of
groceries I mean it that's it's really
miserable and difficult so that was
another huge thing he's just so much
more receptive to a different idea which
was not the case before
go up up oh
he can now Motor plant if he has an idea
that was not there before his cognitive
levels have increased significantly
go fast
[Applause]
I've definitely seen it become more
flexible because he would want to do
things only the way he wanted to do it
and we couldn't get
um any
um change or new ideas and new ideas was
really hard for us since then he's
giving me a lot more new ideas he's
doing much better with some language and
he's also started to motor pan things so
the other day too he was here he saw
this and the ramp was on the other side
of the room and he went to try and get
the ramp he's never ever had a plan
about how he was going to do a task so
that was very novel and very new for him
so we've definitely seen progress in
lots of different areas
I've been working with him since he was
18 months old so it's almost three years
now at the same time it's also giving
him the feeling of where his body is in
space so how do I learn to plan and to
figure out how to do things by having a
really good internal body awareness yeah
you are ready yeah
[Music]
okay
so every day it's something new where
we're both shocked since the kalahar
family was making the Trek to M cell for
Beckham's autism they decided to see if
fetal stem cells would also benefit
their oldest son Matt Jr my older son
has
um convergence insufficiency in ADHD I
never thought he would make it into
college
I was very skeptical very skeptical it's
helped me tremendously with just one
treatment in terms of school I've I've
gone from middle school I've had in high
school as well almost flunking staying
up until two in the morning with my
parents to so they could help me because
I couldn't
until now I'm making Straight A's and
B's which is phenomenal and then I'm
looking into the the future semesters to
take on a larger workload because it
seems more doable more possible so
you're saying in the four month time
that you're making better grades than
you've ever had yeah actually beneficial
yeah absolutely without taking
medication now at least winging off a
dosage I would go from pills like
Vyvanse ADHD Adderall in these past four
months it's been tremendously helpful
one of the most important things he ever
said to me was Mom thank you so much
thank God I don't feel dumb anymore
while Matt Jr received fetal stem cells
in hopes of finding relief for his ADHD
he was also suffering from an overactive
bladder and chronic skin conditions uh
always having these urge I guess urinate
every 15 to 20 minutes throughout the
day entirely to about two months after I
haven't had the urge at all between my
skin I've had acne I've had
uncontrollable it was bacterial acne
I've tried the strongest things up to
Accutane as high as you could go on like
the dosage it would mess up my liver it
would make me feel terrible but honestly
in the past two months I've had skin my
Skin's cleared up on my shoulders my
back mostly around my entire face it's a
tremendous difference as well as all the
eczema around the eyes mainly and then
the arms I've had blotches around the
arms where now it's completely gone and
it's just phenomenal it's crazy and it's
only been one treatment
there was nothing that mainstream
medicine had we'd been to absolutely
every doctor we possibly could
I feel like we made the right choice we
did there's no doubt in my mind we had a
lot of information to sift through and
like everybody else and and seeking
information and trying to be well
informed it took us literally eight
months just to weed through what we
thought would be the best option for us
I cannot say how thrilled I am with the
results it's one thing to have everyone
around Beckham notice such great
improvements after getting fetal stem
cell therapy just four months prior and
it's another to review the results of
his autism spectrum test or [__] 2. we
obtained these test results from
Beckham's neurologist Beckham's last
[__] 2 test was in December of 2013
where he scored a 22 which fell into the
moderate to severe range on the autism
spectrum however while I was visiting
the kalahars in November of 2016 another
[__] 2 test was performed which revealed
a score of 15 a seven point reduction
showing Beckham now in the moderate
autism spectrum these results occurred
after only one round of fetal stem cell
therapy Beckham has not been taking any
medications during this time I'm so
excited I can't even it's it's so
exciting for the first time I see the
light in the end of the tunnel I see a
light I haven't seen a light in a long
time
back and Kiev after my three-day
treatment was complete I spent a couple
of days with Dr karpenko as he told me
the entire story of how M cell came to
be while showing me around key Dr
carpenko had worked directly in
cooperation with Ukraine's Ministry of
Health allowing M cell to freely and
legally come into existence it was since
1991 or that such technology for
clinical use it was made and we use it
about 25 years this year 25 years
already and it is stable we can predict
what is going on
predicted timing of results
understand how it will behave our
treatment will behave in different kinds
of diseases in different ages in
different conditions of the patients and
also this was the start of clinical use
of fetal essential transplantation not
just a discovery of fetal stem cells or
the first pioneer transplantation
I took a tour of M cell's research
facilities and quality control Labs I
wanted to get a fully comprehensive
understanding of how these cells are
harvested and tested before being
administered to patients the process
begins specifically between 7 and 12
weeks of gestation where the fetal
material from a legal voluntary abortion
with the donor's consent arrives at M
cell within two hours of the abortion
procedure this feature material then
enters M cell's biotechnology Laboratory
Christina msel's CEO and overall
supervisor for all of M cells harvesting
and quality control Laboratories not
everybody can come inside I know I feel
very very privileged I would love you to
process of the extraction
extract cells but I'm a nursery but we
cannot film it that's okay that's great
thank you
so let's go yep after M cells scientists
extract more than a dozen different
relevant categories of fetal material in
their biotechnology laboratory the fetal
stem cells are immediately sent to the
cryopreservation department where they
are then suspended using a special
proprietary method once the cells are
successfully suspended they are then
simultaneously sent to three different
departments during the research phase
the cells are tested for their
functional activity viability and
consistency they need to make sure they
are using healthy and thriving cells
capable of expanding and replicating
once injected into the body this
viability testing process also involves
a state-of-the-art
laser-based flow cytometer which is
capable of analyzing counting and
sorting the fetal stem cells in real
time up to a thousand particles per
second while that is happening this
exact same batch of fetal stem cells is
also being tested in M cell's
microbiology lab where each batch of
fetal stem cells is tested to make sure
they do not contain any harmful bacteria
or contamination this same batch of
fetal stem cells is also sent to the
polymerase Chain Reaction laboratory
where M cells scientists carefully test
each batch of fetal stem cells for any
harmful viruses polymerase chain
reaction is the method of molecular
Diagnostics that allows M cells
scientists to identify a single copy of
the DNA and RNA of harmful pathogens
m-cell's testing process is repeated
three times to make absolutely certain
that their fetal stem cells are up to
the highest standards of viability and
safety before being administered to
patients
M cell has the largest fetal stem cell
Bank in the world quite often people
confuse fetal stem cells with embryonic
stem cells when they aren't remotely the
same thing an embryonic stem cell is
harvested within the first five days of
development in a Petri dish after
artificial fertilization unlike fetal
stem cells embryonic stem cells haven't
formed any organs or valuable tissue to
take advantage of regardless of the
misleading hype in the news media not to
mention that embryonic stem cells can be
quite dangerous the ability of embryonic
stem cells to form non-cancerous tumors
called teratomas is one of their
defining traits it's a frightening one
particularly for those who hope to
develop therapies from these cells in
many cultures including the Ukrainian
culture the vocabulary word for fetal
simply doesn't exist which only adds to
the confusion as in some cultures the
terms fetal and embryonic are used
interchangeably hence the name m cell I
had the opportunity to read a draft
manuscript of Dr karpenko's soon to be
published paper summarizing the last 25
years of fetal stem cell transplantation
in it he mentions the first patient they
ever treated a young 14 year old boy
with severe aplastic anemia a plastic
anemia occurs when the body's immune
system turns on itself and attacks the
blood's platelets and the red and white
blood cells otherwise known as bone
marrow failure the only potential cure
mainstream medicine offers for this
disease is a life-threatening bone
marrow transplant and the only way to
stay alive waiting for a bone marrow
transplant is to undergo constant blood
transfusions this disease afflicts up to
900 people per year in the United States
dates so we decided to track this
patient down 25 years later who is now a
thriving husband and father living in
Switzerland we had a lovely Skype call
with dimitro from his home in
Switzerland and his parents who still
live in the Ukraine dimitro was cured of
a plastic anemia 25 years ago after only
two fetal stem cell transplants dimitro
did not undergo any other therapies
other than fetal stem cell transplants
completely restoring his entire bone
marrow ever since
the fact that fetal stem cells have only
nine months to create an entire human
being should help illustrate the power
of these cells in comparison to any
other stem cell type when they enter
your body they are programmed to seek
out anything that needs repair
redefining the meaning of the power of
Mother Nature
for the record I couldn't find anyone to
agree to go on camera that opposed fetal
stem cell therapy I reached out to
countless anti-abortion politicians
including Mrs Blackburn from Tennessee
who chaired an anti-fetal stem cell
Congressional Hearing in 2016. cell
human fetal tissue for a profit you
break the law donate fetal tissue with
zero profit you are within the law I
also reached out to anti-abortion
activist and Christian evangelist
Franklin Graham Billy Graham's son who
also refused to participate my contact
with various stem cell experts had
similar responses when I contacted James
Thompson Time magazine's man who brought
you stem cells for his participation in
this documentary as a stem cell expert
his response was simply I'm sorry but it
is out of my area of expertise
gaining legal access to fetal stem cell
therapy in the United States is
currently next to Impossible cerm is
running a handful of clinical trials but
these trials are currently 12 years and
at least a billion dollars away from
meeting fda's requirements for Market
approval and that's just for one ailment
it could theoretically take hundreds of
years and billions of dollars to obtain
approval for all relevant ailments the
problem we have is we don't have after
15 years of this regulatory Paradigm in
place we don't have anything close
to being reviewed by the FDA for
approval but I think when sir steps back
and looks at that regulatory framework
we think well if there were something in
the middle that weren't that wasn't as
daunting as the current regulatory
approach instead of taking these
Innovative cell therapies overseas or
having them be under the surveillance of
FDA would they just not come into the
fold and and do the work necessary to
show their safe and effective in a
timely fashion in a way which which from
a cost standpoint enabled them to be
successful there are only a handful of
places in the world one can obtain fetal
stem cells another company is stemetica
based in San Diego who first made
headlines in 2015 after treating hockey
Legend Gordie Howe in Tijuana Mexico
Gordy Howe one of the greatest hockey
players of all time was on his deathbed
last year after suffering a stroke his
son Dr Murray Howe had actually started
writing his father's you when he
received a phone call from stomatica a
San diego-based stem cell company Gordie
Howe's stroke had left him unable to
walk but within eight hours of his first
stem cell treatment he sat up in his bed
at the clinic but he said well I'll just
walk to the bathroom so well you can't
walk he said well the hell I can't and
uh he sits up and he puts his feet over
the edge of the bed and I was absolutely
astounded that he could do that when
Gordie Howe's story first broke in 2015
we reached out to CTV the Canadian news
organization that first covered the
story they told us that Gordy received
neural stem cells from a sample of fetal
tissue from a 12-week-old fetus and bone
marrow immune cells from a healthy 21
year old donor from a U.S tissue bank
once the American Media got a hold of
this story still Medica began getting
some negative publicity for using fetal
stem cells stemetica then suddenly began
claiming that the fetal brain main
tissue they were using was not from a 12
week old fetus but a 14 to 16 week old
fetus instead claiming that they're
really considered legally adult stem
cells even if they're fetal derived to
make matters more confusing if the bone
marrow immune cells stomatica is using
are from a 21 year old donor and is
being injected into patients like Gordie
Howe without genetically matching these
patients why do we have so many bone
marrow Registries around the world if
they are successfully giving mature 21
year old bone marrow cells to patients
without matching them genetically
semitica failed to respond to any of our
questions or requests to participate in
this documentary Gordie Howe passed away
at 88 from what his family says was
simply old age
it's important to realize that just how
not all stem cell types are created
equal of the handful of the American
fetal stem cell experts that agreed to
speak to me privately and not on camera
most said that replicating the cells
wasn't a good idea as the cells could
not only lose efficacy but they also run
the risk of maturing beyond their
productive role I have scoured the Earth
for any other institution outside of M
cell in Kiev Ukraine that harvests sorts
tests and provides true fetal stem cell
therapy they don't exist M cell is
literally the only company on Earth
doing this I have also decided to make a
sequel to this documentary set to be
released in 2022 where most all of the
patients who once went to Stem Cell of
America are now going to emsel
interested in going email me I love
answering questions about this therapy
in cases of diabetes
of the child who has initial face of
diabetes 1 is sentenced to very low
quality of life to a debilitating
complications in many cases this will
end with a kidney transplantation with
blindness with amputations of extreme
awful length of food and so on but in
case of our
intervention in the very beginning of
this disease we will change the destiny
of the child he will keep
diabetic patient
but the cause for diabetes will be very
mild with no complications at all the
results are not effective in 100 they
are effective in 70 but in cases of
uncurable diseases it is Sun
wrapping up my three-year Journey
investigating this story I tend to take
greater notice of the millions of people
around me we certainly have no shortage
of human beings especially when I see
homeless people sharing the same space
as millionaires we are clearly still
struggling to take care of the people
that are already Among Us the human race
collectively aborts up to 50 million
fetuses every year whether we agree with
abortion or not it doesn't matter if we
are pro-life or pro-choice we are going
to do nothing to change the hard reality
that people are going to continue to
seek abortions especially when 22
percent of all pregnancies in the United
States end in abortion the argument that
women will start getting pregnant on
purpose just to have an abortion to
provide more fetal stem cells is well
absurd no woman wants an abortion unless
that abortion is absolutely necessary
and if she does to use that path how is
that decision any of our business
so uh what do we have to say about all
this
except all I can say is we're not going
to see this technology available to the
Americans anytime soon between the
anti-abortionists that do not want to
see this happen and the pharmaceutical
industry that will take full advantage
of that and not allow this to happen
this is probably the biggest threat to
anything the industry's ever seen so
many people ask me how I am doing on the
therapy and and frankly I feel amazing I
can't really speak for a stem cell of
America so much as MC
as I was sort of rushed in and out 30
minutes no medical testing I did blood
work before and after nothing
significant changed in my health but
with himself I had a full ultrasound
that showed a slightly in enlarged
pancreas and that normalized in only
four months completely normal my
cholesterol was really really high on my
based on my blood test but uh not
anymore four months later my cholesterol
normalized you can't do that without
Pharma drugs so um it's pretty
remarkable it is my hope that everyone I
know including my loved ones get a
chance to get this therapy but perhaps
the most noticeable thing that happened
to me that I experienced shortly after
the cells was uh aside from like skin
things clearing up I slept better uh
energy increased dramatically but my
libido exploded absolutely exploded like
an 18 year old again and uh that's not
reason enough so I felt quite privileged
as I'm only one in 15 000 people across
this whole planet to have had fetal stem
cells and
all right all right thank you
no problem no problem
[Music]